welche parallelen gibt es denn zu dem
fall maddie und inga welche parallelen
gibt es dort seit wissen wir dass auf
dem grundstück das der verdächtige vor
zehn jahren auf einer
zwangsversteigerung erworben hat die
polizei bereits im jahr 2016 im februar
eine durchsuchung gemacht hat damals
wurde ihm der besitz von
kinderpornografie und illegaler
müllentsorgung vorgeworfen
deshalb wurde das grundstück damals von
einer ganzen hundertschaften durchsucht
weil das ja unzugänglich ist und hier an
verschiedenen stellen gegraben werden
musste man fand damals eine leiche von
einem hund und daneben auch einen stick
mit kinderpornografischem inhalt
nachbarn ab und erzählt dass christian g
hierländer gehaust hat er hat in diesen
alten hallen hier hinter mir zu sehen in
einem wohnmobil gewohnt hatte keinen
strom kein wasser aber hat den leuten
erzählt dass er großes vor habe er heute
wie eine werkstatt einrichten nachbarn
dass er zu geld gemacht habe beim
holzhandel in portugal und die leute hat
sich natürlich gewundert warum der
vermeintlich reiche mann hielt und
kostenplan viele versprechen gleich
weiter mit die wir wollen einmal noch
auf eine zusammenfassung des
vermisstenfalls enger schauen wo steckt
inga fünf jahre sind seit dem
verschwinden des kleinen mädchens aus
schönebeck in sachsen-anhalt vergangen
es ist der zweite mai 2015 die damals
fünfjährige inga bricht mit ihrer
familie zu einem ausflug auf mit ihren
eltern und geschwistern geht es zum
wilhelms hof in stendal der wilhelms hof
ist ein diakoniewerk eine
begegnungsstätte für suchtkranke
menschen und menschen mit behinderung
der ort liegt mitten im wald als die
eltern am abend ein grillfest
vorbereiten sollen die kinder im wald
holz sammeln
doch inga kehrt nie zurück tagelang
durch streifenpolizisten mit
hundertschaften das angrenzende
waldgebiet
such hunde und hubschrauber sind im
einsatz fahndungsaufrufe werden
veröffentlicht doch ohne erfolg
jede spur von inga verläuft sich im 3500
hektar großen wald wir haben gerade
nochmal die zusammenfassung des falls
inga gehört vielleicht kannst du uns
noch mal sagen welche indizien sprechen
genau gegen ihn wie belastend sind die
indizien mann hat mehrere konkrete
spuren wo man sagen kann es gibt eine
räumliche nähe zu dem fall
am tag vor dem flinken von inga hat
christian beer einen unfall gehabt auf
der a2 die bewegungsprofile zeigen dass
er sich also deutlich in dem bereich
bewegt hat wo auch immer vom ist
verschwunden ist da er an sich ein sehr
mobiler täter war der immer unterwegs
war verschiedene fahrzeuge genutzt hat
dafür wollen die ermittler wissen ob er
vielleicht doch auch hier war und ziel
gemacht hat